welcome to this video playing it's
Donnie trophy I'm the opponent's rating
also get down simply because I'm playing
so badly and lose rating when I get
worse opponents and that there was a
mouse club I wanted to play D file but
ok is playing this this weird weird kind
of thing totally not developing and so
on so how can I try to play can go d 5
maybe no ads interesting question both
good Queen D 5 is probably better okay
now I'm losing that game also then I'm
kind of stopping this okay so what now
Bishop f5 or come on
white resign okay I'm not losing that
game that's a good sign that's really
not sure what what what this was but
okay here white is already in some some
trouble some bit bit strange here Y go
see form and this whole thing yeah it's
difficult yet to find a move that the
engine wants to play like that and gives
black a clear advantage but not a win
but here he I'm probably just winning on
Bishop d7 is also strongly but after
that that's also yeah I mean it's a bit
much this thing this thing queen bee
three and I b3 is the worst the worst
problem and then there's also this kind
of thing yeah totally here in that pin
check yeah it loses an exchanger maybe
you should have continued considering my
my current form but thankfully he
resigns so I got a point yippee okay
what thanks for watching